[موسيقى]
في الوقت الذي يغدق الزعيم الصيني على
روسيا بعبارات الصداقه والوفاء تناور بكين
بكل اوراقها داخل فناء روسيا الخلفي تطلق
بكين في الوقت نفسه مبادره خمسه زائد واحد
التي تستهدف دول اسيا الوسطى والتي وصفت
طويلا بانها حديقه موسكو الخلفيه لقاء
الرئيس الصيني بزعماء دول وسط اسيا تم
ترتيبه قبل مغادرته الى روسيا وهو ما
وصفته المعارضه الروسيه بخساره الحرب
الكبرى بجعل شريك اقتصادي يتحول الى عدو
غير معلن بعد ان تحولت مناطق النفوذ الى
ساحه تنافس مباحه الصين لن تواجه الوجود
الروسيه التاريخيه فقط بل ايضا لاعبين جدد
اهمهم تركيا التي اطلقت مشروع توحيد
العائله التركيه بما يجمعها من دين ولغه
شعارات شعبويه تقول الصين اضافه الى انها
لن تقف امام مشروعها البراغماتي الذي جاء
بمشاريع واستثمارات بمليارات الدولارات
وبالمقابل عين بكين على الطاقه
الكازاخستانيه واليد العامله الرخيصه في
تاجكستان اتركمانستان امام الوضع الجديد
اطلقت بروكسل مبادره اوروبيه وعلى لسان
ممثل خارجيتها جوزيف بوريل لاستماله دول
وسط اسيا نحو المشروع الاوروبي كبديل عن
التدخل الروسي الذي عرقل انشاء علاقات
متعدده الاطراف مع هذه الدول
[موسيقى]
اما موسكو فلا تجد الوقت مناسبا لفتح جبهه
جديده
الاولويات للحرب في اوكرانيا والانتصار في
نظر الكرملين كفيل بفرض واقع جيوسياسي
جديد
ومصير وقوف كييف في وجه موسكو سيكون اكبر
ضامن لولاء بقيه دول رابطه الدول المستقله